[Music]
why decide to dedicate
your energy
to
matcha at least in part well let me say
on the second day that i was in japan
back in in november of 1959 my host
mother took me next door to meet her
neighbor who was a tea ceremony
practitioner so the three of us sat
around and this woman did a tea ceremony
and presented me with a bowl of matcha
and i was completely taken by it first
by the color uh also by the chas and the
whisk which i just thought was marvelous
and the taste of it i fell in love with
it so
i began
when i began going to japan more
regularly in the 1970s every time i was
there i'd bring macha back to the states
and turn people on to it no nobody'd
ever heard of it here
and i just thought this was a great
thing to make available before i knew
anything about its health benefits and i
partnered with a matcha company in japan
and
began selling it through my website
again like the beneficial plant
association way ahead of its time
this was in the 1980s and uh
you know i just always thought this
would be a great thing here so when i
had the chance
when i saw matcha becoming popular here
it bothered me that so few people had
access to good matcha because if if
matcha is not
prepared correctly and if it's not
stored correctly it oxidizes very
quickly because it has such a huge
surface area and it turns it loses that
bright green color it loses the good
flavor has a bitter taste and many
people here never tasted really good
matcha so i was determined to make that
available and that's why i started this
company and we got the great coup was
getting the url matcha.com people in
japan can't believe that we got that but
there it is
let's discuss the health benefits and
let me also just ask a question
for myself i would imagine most people
who listen to this and have had tea
before they imagine
tea leaves or a tea bag put into water
you steep and then you remove the tea
leaves and you're left with this colored
water and that is what you drink
but
matcha is
if if i'm understanding correctly whole
leaf
so it would there would also be an
incredible importance or you could place
incredible importance on
quality or sourcing in so much as if
you're consuming whole leaf
tea that has been exposed to pesticides
you're going to be getting a much higher
toxin load as well is that am i thinking
about that correctly you are and there
is organic matcha available but not
nearly as in great supply as
conventional matcha
but we've monitored matcha for pesticide
levels and are assured that this is not
not a problem but the way match has
grown how it's prepared
it's a long labor-intensive process and
much is the only form of tea
in which the whole leaf is consumed as
you say
i think we have the most research on the
health benefits of green tea in general
and there are many forms of green tea
that i like but matcha has the highest
level of antioxidants and of l-theanine
the calming amino acid that modifies the
effects of caffeine so it's unique in
that regard and i think there are
health benefits of matcha that are
distinctive among all forms of tea
how does l-theanine modify the
effects of
caffeine i think it it takes the jittery
edge off of caffeine i think the effects
of caffeine and tea and coffee are very
different coffee produces i think a
jangling effect in many people there's
often a crash after a period of
stimulation
many coffee drinkers are physically
addicted to it and have a withdrawal
syndrome when they stop you don't see
anything like that with with tea and i
think some of that is because the
l-theanine has a calming effect that
that changes the effect of caffeine and
as i say matcha has more l-theanine in
it than any other form of tea
why is that is it that it's contained in
some of the fibrous
components of the leaf that are
discarded when it's prepared no i think
it has to do with the way the tea is
grown because what's unique about matcha
is that about three weeks before harvest
the plants are heavily shaded
with
shade cloth that cuts out about 70 80
percent of the sunlight and in response
to that the leaves grow
bigger and thinner and produce higher
amounts of antioxidants and l-theanine
so i think that's very unique there's
some the same shading process is used to
make a very high quality brewed green
tea called gyokuro that i'm sure you're
familiar with it's quite delicious so
that also has these high levels
that's fascinating to me so it almost
seems like an adaptive stress response
by the plant to fortify itself well it's
trying to get it makes more leaf surface
in an effort to get more you know light
exposure and it develops more
chlorophyll which accounts for the
bright
color of matcha so i don't know how the
japanese discovered this shading process
but it is unique
and for people who have not seen even if
you never have matcha i certainly would
suggest that you consider it but even if
you're never going to drink matcha
go find
photographs of
exceptionally good matcha the color
is unlike anything else you have ever
seen in your life it is like a
phosphorescent almost a phosphorescent
green and i'm biased because green is my
favorite color oh good
it really is it really is something
something special can i say that uh
machikari i think has some of the finest
matcha available we're very particular
about our sourcing and listeners to your
podcast can get a generous discount if
they use the code tim
that's a listener exclusive folks so
there you go tim and that's easy to
remember matcha.com
dot
m-a-t-c-h-a-dot-com
you